I said ma here's some BuzzFeed lists I
saw recently look at this one 7up skirts
of Scottish guys in kilts that's not a
good list who wants to see that
that's awful look at this one 12 rescue
dogs that regret ever leaving the pound
look at this one 8 Sizzlin summer dental
dam flavors
here's 123 hipsters who drink IPA but
don't know what it stands
I like this one nine incredibly
depressing Oh faces that's my o face
here's one six alpacas that can pass as
llamas that's a bad list look at this
one sixteen people in comas who are
crushing it look at this one 11
Neanderthals who died feeling
unfulfilled Gore did want more though
this one 23 most popular Star Wars
action figures removed from people's
rectums I take your gasp as a sign that
you approved by the way though this one
8 mimes the Nazis made talk
I don't care what you think I'm standing
by that one that's a good one
anyone weird mine is torture time okay
look at this one 114 trees gene simmons
claims we've had sex with
and finally nine most gruesome crime
scenes reconstructed in Lego
[Applause]
you